[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم عثمان اي
فرح وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من هذه الصوره لمبنى
الامم المتحده حيث اعتمدت الجمعيه العامه
اليوم قرارا يستنكر اي اعمال ترتكب ضد
الرموز الدينيه والكتب المقدسه ويعتبرها
انتهاكا للقانون الدولي الى واشنطن ومن
هناك اعلن عن مساعدات عسكريه اضافيه
لاوكرانيا بقيمه 400 مليون دولار تشمل
ذخائر لانظمه دفاع جوي من طرازات وقاذفات
صواريخ هاي مارس الى الجزائر وتحديدا
بجايه حيث تسببت حرائق الغابات في سقوط
قتلى وجرحى بالاضافه الى خسائر ماديه
بطبيعه الحال
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
تصعيد اسرائيلي في الضفه الغربيه قوات
الاحتلال تقتل ثلاثه عناصر في كتائب
القسام في نابلس حركه حماس تشدد على ان
استهداف كوادرها لم يضعف من تمدد الحركه
وضرباتها السلطه الفلسطينيه تعتبر مقتل
الشبان الثلاثه جريمه حرب ووزير الخارجيه
البريطاني يؤكد عبر الجزيره ضروره تحقيق
حل الدولتين
روسيا تعلن واحباط محاوله هجوم بمسييرتين
بحريتين على سفينه دوريه في البحر الاسود
يؤكد عزمه على حمايه الموانئ وممرات
الحبوب من الصواريخ والمسيرات الروسيه
وبريطانيا تتهم موسكو بتصعيد حملتها
لتدمير الصادرات الغذائيه عبر استهداف
السفن في البحر الاسود
وفي التطورات الميدانيه في السودان الجيش
يستهدف تجمعات الدعم السريع شماليا
وطائراته تكثف التحليق في اجواء مدن
الخرطوم تبادل كثيف للنيران في نيالا في
ولايه دارفور والاتحاد الاوروبي يدرس
مقترحات لتشديد العقوبات على اطراف الصراع
في السودان تشمل حظر سفر وتجميد اصول
وحسابات مصرفيه
محكمه مصريه تجدد ادراج صحفيين في شبكه
الجزيره ضمن قائمه الارهاب شبكه الجزيره
تندد بالقرار وتدعو المنظمات الدوليه
للضغط على السلطات المصريه للكف عن
الاجراءات التي تنتهك لحقوق والحريات
الامم المتحده تجدد الاعراب عن قلقها بشان
وضع صحفي الجزيره في مصر والمعهد الدولي
للصحافه يدين القرار ويقول للجزيره ان
السلطات المصريه تسيء استخدام تهمه
الارهاب
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا اقرار الامم المتحده بفشل
الجهود العالميه للحد من الجوع وكشفها
زياده عدد الجوعة عالميا استطلاع ارائكم
بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي في رايكم ما افضل السبل
لمعالجه القصور في جهود الحد من الجوع عبر
العالم اما الاجابه فقد جاءت على النحو
الاتي
31% قالوا ان افضل السبل هي استثمارات
طويله الاجل لنظم غذائيه افضل بينما اختار
36% التصويت لصالح مراجعه البلدان الناميه
لاولويات الانفاق العام اخيرا قال نحو 33%
انهم مع اتفاقات دوليه للحد من ارتفاع
اسعار الغذاء هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على
منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم الدخول
عبر صفحه التصويت وذلك من خلال مسح رمز
كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيه ودوريه
وفي الحصاد تتابعون ايضا
بدء سحب النفط من ناقله صافر المهجوره
قباله اليمن والامم المتحده تقول انها
عمليه نزع فتي لما قد يكون اكبر قنبله
موقوته في العالم
[موسيقى]
فالاضراب الشامل مدينه نابلس حدادا على
استشهاد ثلاثه شبان برصاص الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وقالت حركه حماسنا الشهداء هم
كوادر في كتائب القسام وقضوا في اشتباك
مسلح مع قوات الاحتلال من جانبه قال الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان الفلسطينيين حاولوا مهاجمه
قواته قرب جبل جرزين في المدينه صباح
اليوم واعلن احتجاز جثمنه
غضب في نابلس وعموم الضفه بعد قتل قوه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لثلاثه من ابنائها
وهي الحادثه الاولى التي تشهد سقوط شهداء
منذ اجتياح جنين ومخيمها سعد ماهر الخراز
ومنتصر سلامه ونور العارضه شبان اعلنت
كتائب القسام انهم من كوادرها قتلتهم قوه
الاحتلال اثناء توجههم الى تنفيذ هجوم على
اهداف معاديه الجيش الاسرائيلي وبعد
احتجاز الجثامين قال ان المجموعه حاولت
مهاجمه قواته قرب جبل جرزين في نابلس تم
انطلاق سيارتين اسعاف من مركز اسعاف نابلس
الى موقع الحدث لكن تم منعنا بعنجهيه من
قبل قوات الاحتلال من الوصول الى موقع
الحدث شباب صفوا السياره نزلوا في سلاحهم
بلشوا طخوا بعض
حماس اكدت ان الحادثه جريمه لن تضعف من
تمدد الحركه او ضرباتها اما الرئاسه
الفلسطينيه فشددت على ان عمليه القتل
اليوميه والجرائم هذه لن تجلب الامن
والاستقرار لاحد قوات الاحتلال كانت في
حاله تاهب منذ الصباح تعزيزات امنيه في
اكثر من مكان خصوصا في بلده حوار التي
شهدت في الساعات الماضيه عمليه اطلاق نار
على حافله تقل مستوطنين رغم ان الضفه
الغربيه تشهد اقتحامات ومواجهات متواتره
بين الاحتلال وفصائل المقاومه الا ان
الاشتباكات الاخيره كشفت عن اعلان الفصائل
وتحديدا كتائب القسام انها موجوده بشكل
مباشر بمواجهه قوات الاحتلال لا عبر تبني
عمليات تاخذ طابعا فرديا او نغي منفذها
من غزه معنا الدكتور صالح النعامي الخبير
في الشؤون الاسرائيليه سيد نعامه ما دلاله
تزايد وتنامي وجود الفصائل الفلسطينيه
المسلحه في الضفه الغربيه
هذا استاذ عثمان يعني نتيجه طبيعيه لوجود
الاحتلال لا احد يعني يتطوع للقيام بهذا
الدور الا لوجود احتلال ووجود الاحتلال
يفرض على الشعب الفلسطيني كما على اي شعب
حر ان يقاوم هذا الاحتلال هذا اولا ثانيا
هذا جاء بعد فشل مشروع التسويه السياسيه
الذي تشبتت فيه القياده القياده منظمه
التحرير الحاليه السلطه ثانيا بسبب تعاظم
الاجرام الاسرائيلي سواء على صعيد التهويد
الاستيطان افلات يد
المستوطنين اليهود ليعرفوا فسادا وبالتالي
هذه نتيجه طبيعيه
للواقع الاحتلال وهنا فقط استذكر ما قاله
براك رئيس الوزراء ورئيس اركان الجيش
الاسرائيلي السابق مع معايده التصرفه عام
1991 قال لو ولدت فلسطينيا لان ضممت الى
فصيل من فصائل المقاومه يعني هذا حتى
تسليم من قبل الصهاينه منه اقبال على
المقاومه بين العمل المقاوم هو الامر
الطبيعي جدا الذي يمكن ان يصلكم اي شيء
مواجهه الاحتلال ولكن ما هو سبب اخفاق
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في منع تزايد وجود
المسلحين في الضفه رغم كل ما قام به من
الناحيه الاستخباراتيه والعسكريه
واستخدام كل الوسائل الممكنه عبر يعني
مجموعات النخبه التي استخدمها في في الضفه
الغربيه
لا يمكن لقوه احتلال مهما كانت ان تنتصر
على اراده شعب مع متشبت للحياه ومعني
ومصمم ان يدفع كل الاتمان اللازمه للتخلص
من هذا الاحتلال هذا هذا قدر الشعب
الفلسطيني وبالتالي الحركات المقاومه من
خلال تجربه تجربه المقاومه الطويل مع هذا
الاحتلال اكتسبت خبره واكتسبت قدره على
التعاطي مع
والتكيف مع وسائل الاحتلال انه بعد
بدء عمليه الصير الواقي جيش الاحتلال شن
ما يسمى او تبنى استراتيجيه اسرافيه
استراتيجيه جازش العشب يعني استثاف بيئه
المقاومه من جذورها لكن عليك ان تلاحظ
الاستاذ عثمان انه العمل التنظيم العمل
المقام ذو صفه التنظيميه يعني ترعرع وتجسد
ويعني تعاظم في الفتره الاخيره تحديدا في
المناطق في وجود نفوذ السلطه الفلسطينيه
للاسف الشديد في محدود يعني تحديد منطقه
جنين ومنطقه نابلس وهذا يدل على شيء فانما
يدل للاسف الشديد على الدور السلبي الذي
تلعب السلطه الفلسطينيه عن طريق التعاون
الامني في توفير بيئه لا تسمح بتعاظم بيئه
العمل لتنظيم المقاوم لذلك نجد التركيز
العامل المقاوم في هاتين المنطقه على وجه
الخصوص بهذه القوه شكرا جزيلا دكتور صالح
النعامي الخبير في الشؤون الاسرائيليه
حدثنا من غزه
[موسيقى]
الى تداعيات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا فقد
جدد الرئيس الاوكراني فلودي التاكيد انه
سيوفر حمايه للموانئ وممر الحبوب في البحر
الاسود في مواجهه ما سماه ارهاب الصواريخ
والمسيرات الروسيه في المقابل قال نائب
وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
ان العوده الى العمل لاتفاقيه الحبوب
مستحيله من دون مشاركه روسيا من جانبها
اكدت المندوبه البريطانيه في مجلس الامن
الدولي ان لدى لندن معلومات تشير الى ان
روسيا قد تهاجم السفن المدنيه في البحر
الاسود
لم تنم ليلتها على كيف تقاطرت المسيره
الروسيه لكن الهجوم السادس من نوعه خلال
شهر يقول الاوكرانيون انهم ابطلوه
يتحدث الروس في المقابل عن احباط هجوم
اوكراني ليس بنك اهدافه على اليابسه انه
بحسب موسكو هجوم بزورقين مسيرين على احدى
سفن اسطولها في البحر الاسود تصدت له
سفينه دوليه
ما يدور هنا على الجبهه البحريه لا يبدو
خارج سياق الجدل بشان حركه الملاحه
البحريه وان كانت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
اعلنت استئنافها في خليج سيفا ستوبل
بالبحر الاسود
وليست هذه التطورات كما يبدو ببعيده عن
ملف تصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه تؤكد موسكو
استحاله العوده للاتفاق الذي يتيح ذلك دون
مشاركتها في حين تتوافق كييف ولندن على
اهميه وصول امدادات الحبوب الى الاسواق
العالميه
ويقول رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشيسوناك
ان بلاده تعمل من قرب مع تركيا لاعاده
العمل باتفاق تصدير الحبوب عبر البحر
الاسود
الاوكرانيون يزيدون على ذلك تعهدنا بتوفير
حمايه للموانئ وممر الحبوب
اجتماعنا اليوم مع القاده ناقشنا بالتفصيل
سبل حمايه مؤسساتنا وموانئنا وممر الحبوب
في البحر الاسود في مواجهه ارهاب الصواريخ
والمسيرات الروسيه نحن الان بصدد اعداد رد
قوي على هذا الارهاب الروسي
في دائره الارهاب ايضا تضع اوكرانيا
الهجوم الروسي بمسيرات على البنى التحتيه
لميناء الدانوب ومستودعات الحبوب جنوب
غربي اوديسا المساله لا تقلق الاوكرانيين
وحدهم ما تفعله روسيا في اوديسا مدمر
مازلنا قلقين من احتمال ان يوسع جيش
الروسي رقعه اهدافه على منشات الحبوب
الاوكرانيه لتشمل هجمات على سفن مدنيه في
البحر الاسود وقد حذرنا من ان روسيا قد
تهاجم اهدافا مدنيه ثم تلقي اللوم على
الاوكرانيين بهدف اخفاء مسؤوليتها ونحن
نواصل مراقبه الوضع من كتب
الوضع الميداني ما زال لاهبا على مختلف
الجبهات والمحاور هنا يجدد وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني عزم قوات بلاده مواصله قصف شبه
جزيره القرم وجسرها لتدمير ما يدعوه
الخطوط اللوجستيه للعدو ذاك جنوبا اما على
الجبهه الشرقيه فتستميت القوات الاوكرانيه
في محاولاتها احداث ثوره في الخطوط
العسكريه الروسيه الروس لا يظهرون ايه
تاثر بهجوم اوكرانيا المضاد ذاك الذي قال
الكرملين انه فشل مع ذلك فالحرب ما زالت
قائمه
هذا مجلس الدومه وقد تبنى للتويه قانونا
يرفع سقف سن الاستدعاء للخدمه العسكريه في
روسيا من سبعه وعشرين عاما الى ثلاثين
ينضم الينا من موسكو انوف الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي وبروكسيل فبريسا مدير
السياسه في حلف الناتو السابقا السيد ما
خطوره التصعيد من الطرفين في البحر الاسود
في الحقيقه نحن نشاهد
تصعدا ان روسيا تهدد اوكرانيا وفي الوقت
نفسه تهدد حلفاء اوكرانيا وشرفاء
اوكرانيا في البحر الاسود اذا ما قامت
اوكرانيا بتصدير الحبوب لدول الجنوب وهو
حق اوكرانيا اذا لربما لا يجب ان نسميه
تصعيدا بل تهديدا روسيا موجه الى اوكرانيا
بشان تصدير حبوبها على الامر كذلك
هل يجب ان نقول ان هذا تهديد روسي وليس
تصعيدا من الطرفين
نعم بالفعل ليس
تصعيدا ولكن في الوقت نفسه ليس تهديدا لان
روسيا وفي خلال السنه الماضيه قبلت بفتح
الموانئ البحريه الاوكرانيه من اجل
استخدام هذه الموانئ لتصدير الحبوب
والغرب ايضا
التزم بان روسيا سوف تتمكن من تصدير
صادراتها من الحبوب
والاسمده ولكن الغرب لم يفي بالتزاماته
ولذلك روسيا تود اغلاق هذه الموانئ ومنع
الصادرات الاوكرانيه من الحبوب للدول
الغربيه لان هذه السبل تستخدم من قبل
اوكرانيا من اجل الحصول على معدات عسكريه
والجميع يعرف ان موانئ الاوكرانيه قد
استخدمت كمراكز لنقل الاسلحه والذخيره من
الدول الغربيه الى اوكرانيا
تصعيد شئت غير ذلك ولكن هناك يعني الطرفان
يقولان انه ما يحبطان هجمات من الطرف
الاخر بشكل متكرر هناك توتر بالغ في البحر
الاسود فما مدى خطورته خطورته
رغبه من اطراف غربيه من المملكه المتحده
واوكرانيا بطبيعه الحال في عوده واستمرار
التصدير الحبوب
هل بالفعل هم قادرون على ذلك
رغم الاعتراضات الروسيه والحديث عن
استهداف
محتمل لاي سفينه حتى لو كانت مدنيه وهل
يمكن ان تنفذ روسيا تهديدها وتستهدف حتى
المدنيين في الممرات المائيه
روسيا قد كررت لمرات متعدده ماهيه الشروط
الايه الى فتح ممرات تصدير الحبوب والحفاظ
عليها وشروط سهله للغايه الشروط تقضي بفتح
الاسواق العالميه
للصادرات الزراعيه الروسيه والسماح
بربط البنوك الروسيه
بالبنوك العالميه لتصدير هذه
المنتجات الروسيه
وضروره تصدير الاسمده
الروسيه الى الاسواق العالميه وبالتالي
اذا ما وافقت المملكه المتحده والولايات
المتحده والدول الغربيه على هذه الشروط
سوف توافق روسيا على تمديد اتفاقيه الحكم
باختصار من فضلك الرئيس
الاوكراني يقول انه قادر على حمايه
الممرات
المائيه هل بالفعل هو قادر على ذلك وهو لم
يستطع حمايه مخازن الحبوب الاوكرانيه في
اوديسا
ولكم انتم لا يمكنني ان اعلق بالنيابه عن
اوكرانيا وقدرات الاوكرانيه ولكن يوم غد
ان اوكرانيا تلتقي مع الحلفاء 31 على
مستوى حلف شمال الاطلسي لمناقشه الوضع
ووفقا لاتفاقيه وهي اتفاقيه دوليه ان
الدول المشاطئه للبحر الاسود
يحق لها بالنفاذ الى البحر الاسود من دون
اي عرقله وبالتالي ان روسيا تقوم بخرق
الاتفاقيات الدوليه وسياده اوكرانيا من
خلال منع اوكرانيا من تصدير الزراعه
الخاصه بها من بروكسل فبريس بوثيان مدير
السياسه في حلف الناتو سابقا ومن موسكو
اندريه فرولو الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
شكرا جزيلا لكما
[موسيقى]
مراسل الجزيره بان الطائرات الحربيه
التابعه للجيش السوداني تحلق بصوره مكثفه
منذ الصباح الباكر في سماء مدن العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم والخرطوم بحري واندر
ماء كما افاد باطلاق قوات الدعم السريع
نيران المضادات الارضيه في وسط وجنوب
درمان ووسط الخرطوم مشيرا الى ان صواريخ
موجهه انطلقت من منطقه وادي السيدنا
العسكريه صوب تجمعات الدعم السريع شماليه
ام درمان ياتي هذا بينما افادت مصادر
محليه للجزيره بوقوع تبادل كثيف للنيران
صباح اليوم الثلاثاء بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع في الناحيتين الشماليه
والشرقيه لمدينه نيالا في ولايه جنوب
دارفور
وقال ياسر العطا مساعد القائد العام للجيش
السوداني وعضو مجلس السياده لدى مخاطبته
قوات العمل الخاص انه لا هدنه مع قوات
الدعم السريع الا بعد تنظيف العاصمه
القوميه حسب تعبيرهم واكد العطاء ان اي
هدنه مع قوات الدعم السريع التي وصف
عناصرها باللصوص والمجرمين لن تكون الا
بعد تامين كل المدن في اقليميه كردفان
ودارفور حتى ام دافوج مع حدود افريقيا
الوسطى من انتهاكات قوات الدعم السريع
واكد العطاء استعداد الجيش تامين مخرج امن
لعائله دجلو التي ينتمي اليها قائد الدعم
السريع
بنخليهم يصلوها ويقعدوا فيه يسلموا
الاسلحه الثقيله بعد اي واحد فيهم
ظهر في فيديو باس ينهب يجيب الحاجات
ثروتهم لها كثير من زمان
بينهبوا 15 سنه يا رجل الشعب السوداني
وبعد طريق امن يمشي يقعدوا
يقعدوا مع مافيا
قالت مصادر دبلوماسيه مطلعه في هذه
الاثناء ان الاتحاد الاوروبي يعد اطار عمل
للعقوبات المخصص للسودان ويستهدف الجهات
الرئيسيه الفاعله في الحرب وتشمل العقوبات
المرتقبه حظر السفر وتجميد الاصول
والحسابات المصرفيه واضافت المصادر ان
وثيقه الاقتراح جرى تبادلها بين الدول
الاعضاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي الاسبوع
الماضي وستناقش تفاصيلها خلال الاسابيع
القادمه على ان ينتهي منها بحلول سبتمبر
ايلول المقبل
[موسيقى]
في مصر قالت جريده الوقائع المصريه
الرسميه ان محكمه جددت ادراج عشرات
الاشخاص بينهم صحفيون في شبكه الجزيره ضمن
قوائم الارهاب لخمس سنوات اخرى هذا
واستنكرت شبكه الجزيره العالميه القراره
ودعت السلطات المصريه الى التراجع عنه كما
دعت الشبكه الامم المتحده والمنظمات
الحقوقيه للضغط على السلطات المصريه لوقف
ادراج الصحفيين ضمن هذه القوائم التعسفيه
وجددت الجزيره مطالبتها السلطات المصريه
بالافراج الفوري عن الزميلين ربيع الشيخ
وبهاء الدين ابراهيم المعتقلين وعن كل
الصحفيين المسجونيين في مصر
قرارات جديده ضد الصحفيين في مصر وحريتهم
وفق جريده الوقائع المصريه اعادت محكمه
جنايات القاهره ادراج عشرات المصريين في
قائمه للارهاب لخمس سنوات اخرى بعد انتهاء
مده سابقه لادراجهم التعسفي من هؤلاء
صحفيون بشبكه الجزيره واعلامينا مصريون
يتجدد وضعهم على قوائم ارهاب سيئه السمعه
لسنوات طويله ينظم القانون رقم ثمانيه
لعام 2015 مساله قوائم الكيانات الارهابيه
والارهابيين وفق نص القانون فما الذي
يعنيه ادراج شخص على قوائم الارهاب في مصر
وفق الماده السابعه من القانون وبشان
الافراد يترتب على نشر قرار الادراج وطوال
مدته اثار تحول حياه صاحبها لمعضله من
جميع الجهات فهو يدرج على قوائم منع السفر
وترقب الوصول كما يسحب جواز سفره او يلغى
او يمنع من اصد جواز جديد كما يفقد شرط
حسن السمعه والسيره لتولي الوظائف العامه
او النيابيه وتجمد امواله متى استخدمت في
ممارسه نشاطه الارهابي وفق وصف القانون
وتلك معوقات كبلت حياه الاف المصريين منذ
عام 2013 فان ادرج اسمك وكنت داخل مصر لا
تحتاج افتراضا لجواز سفر فسيخنق رزقك
وفرصك في العمل لحرمانك من شهاده حسن
السيره فضلا عن تجميد اموالك اما المدرجون
خارج الوطن فخلال عشر سنوات انتهت صلاحيات
الاف وثائق السفر ولم يسمح لاصحابها
بتجديدها وولد لعدد منهم اطفال لم
يستطيعوا تسجيلهم فضلا عن الحاقهم بمدارس
لاحقا منذ صدر قانون الكيانات الارهابيه
رقم ثمانيه لعام 2015 وحتى نهايه مارس
الماضي رصدت منظمات حقوقيه ادراج خمسه
الاف وثلاثمائه واربعه عشر شخصا
قوائم الارهاب التي تجدد كل خمس سنوات
بشكل تعسفي ودون محاكمه او سند قانوني
واضح وفضلا عن ادراج الصحفيين على قوائم
الارهاب ما زال خلف الاسوار الزميلان ربيع
الشيخ وبهاء ابراهيم لكن يبقى ان اليه
الادراج على قوائم الارهاب تحديدا باتت
وفق حقوقيين تبتذل جديه محاربه الارهاب في
مصر تبقى تساؤلات كثيره بشان قوائم
الارهاب في مصر وادراج الصحفيين
والسياسيين عليها خاصه في ظل ما يروج له
الاعلام الموالي للسلطه حول سقوف حريه
اخذه في الارتفاع واجواء حوار وطني
وتعدديه تحظى بترويج حافل
وقد عبر فرحان حق نائب المتحدث باسم
الامين العام للامم المتحده عن قلقه بشان
وضع الصحفيين المعتقلين في مصر وردا على
سؤال بشان ادراج صحفي الجزيره في مصر ضمن
قائمه الارهاب قال حق ان المنظمه عبرت
وتكرر التعبير عن قلقها بشان وضع الصحفيين
بمن فيهم صحفي الجزيره
بمن فيهم صحفي الجزيره في مصر ونحن نكرر
هذه المخاوف
من جهتها قالت المقرره الخاصه للامم
المتحده المعنيه بحاله المدافعين عن حقوق
الانسان مري لولو ان حبس الصحفيين امر يجب
الا يحدث واضافت في مقابله مع الجزيره ان
تجديد العقوبات واحكام السجن على الصحفيين
بعد انتهائها امر غير مقبول
من المهم جدا ان تكون هناك حريه للصحافه
بحيث يمكن التعبير عن الاراء وجهات النظر
بطريقه سلميه بالنسبه الي فان حبس واحتجاز
الصحفيين الذين يقومون بعملهم بشكل سلمي
وبالالتزام بالمعايير الدوليه امر لا يجب
ان يحصل ابدا والامر يزداد سوءا حين تكون
هناك احكام وعقوبات بحقهم وتصل الى
مرحلتها النهائيه ومن ثم يفرض عليهم
عقوبات اضافيه
كما اكدت المقرر الخاصه للامم المتحده
المعنيه بحاله المدافعين عن حقوق الانسان
في مقابلتها مع الجزيره ان اليه توجيه
تهمه الارهاب يساء استخدامها في مصر وان
قوانين مكافحه الارهاب في مصر اصبحت بامس
الحاجه الى اصلاحات
نحن نعرف انه في مصر يساء استخدام اليه
توجيه تهمه الارهاب تستخدم للضغط على
المدافعين عن حقوق الانسان والصحفيين وتتم
اعاده تدوير التهم عليهم لابقائهم في
السجن
هذا التجديد للائحه الارهاب التي كان
سينتهي العمل بها امر غير مقبول امر لا
يحتمل اعتقد ان قوانين مكافحه الارهاب
وقوانين العقوبات بامس الحاجه الى اصلاحات
المدافعون عن حقوق الانسان والصحفيون
الذين يمارسون حقوقهم المشروعه بحريه
التعبير لا يجوز ان يتعرضوا لاي مضايقات
او استهداف من قبل الدوله من خلال توجيه
تهم باطله لهم واتهامهم بانهم ارهابيون او
اعضاء في جماعات ارهابيه
اقل افران ماروفيتش المدير التنفيذي
للمعهد الدولي للصحافه في تصريح للجزيره
ان ادراج السلطات المصريه عددا من
الصحفيين على قائمه ارهاب جديده ينافي
مبادئ حقوق الانسان ويعبر عن استغلال كبير
للسلطه واساءه لاستخدام تهم الارهاب
انها رقابه واسكات للاصوات ولا اعتقد انها
اصوات معارضه بل هم صحفيون ينقلون الواقع
فقط وبالتالي ما حصل هو رقابه كليه من
الصعب ان نعلما الى اين تتجه البلاد لكن
تصرفاتها وقراراتها غير ديمقراطيه وضد
مبادئ حقوق الانسان من الواضح ان وضع
الصحفيين في اللائحه دون اعطائهم فرصه
للطعن في هذا القرار او السماح لهم
بالدفاع عن انفسهم هو استغلال كبير للسلطه
وامر يجب انهائه
معنى من لندن ايضا رئيس شبكه الصحافه
الاخلاقيه والامين العام السابق للاتحاد
الدولي للصحفيين سيد وايت كيف
تنظر الى ان يكون صحفيان او صحفيون
في قائمه الارهاب المصري
في الحقيقه اعتقد اننا نتحدث عن امر مخيب
للامل وهذا دليل صادم مجددا بان الحكومه
المصريه ترفض بقبول القواعد الدوليه التي
تحفظ حق التعبير وحق الصحفيين بالعمل
المستقل في هذا القرار يخيب ظننا بشكل
كبير وسوف ياتي هذا القرار بادانات دوليه
من مجموعات معنيه بدفايه عن الصحفيين
وحريه التعبير في كل انحاء العالم وسوف
يؤدي ذلك الى ايضا مظاهرات من ضمن مصر وفي
الشرق الاوسط
برايك كمان حاجه الى استخدام تهمه الارهاب
بالتحديد للصحفيه
[موسيقى]
لا افهم حقا لماذا يقومون بذلك في هذه
المره في هذه المره كان هناك فرصه كبيره
لحكومه السيسي في مصر لكي ترسل مؤشرا
واشاره للمجتمع الدولي وللشعب المصري بان
الحكومه على استعداد للتقبل بشكل اكبر
تعرفون انه في الاشهر الماضيه الحكومه
اطلقت حوارا وطنيا حول مستقبل الدستور في
مصر والتنميه في مصر وكانت هذه اللحظه
لحظه لتكون لحظه مناسبه كي ترسل الحكومه
رساله مفادها بان التغيير على قدم وساق
ولكن حقيقه الامر هي ان الحكومه قررت
باستهداف مستمر لاصوات المعارضين ولذلك
نتحدث عن خطا جسيما ارتكبته الحكومه لان
ذلك يقود الثقه بالحكومه المصريه وثقه
المجتمع الدولي بان مصر جاده بشان التغيير
نحو المستقبل لا ارى ان هذا هو الحال
والتصرف اليوم يجسد مدى الذي يجب على مصر
ان تبذله لكي تصل الى انضمام الى القيم
مجتمع الدولي هذا كان السؤال التالي لك في
الحقيقه كان هناك شعور بان الامور قد بدات
تتحسن ولكن مع قرار
كهذا واضافه صحفيين في الجزيره في قائمه
الارهاب برايك الى اي مدى هذا يضر بصوره
الدوله المصريه وما الذي يمكن ان يترتب
عليه
اعتقد ان
انه خطا جسيم وفظيع وهي فرصه ضائعه ضيعتها
الحكومه المصريه بنسبه الى التاثير هذا
قيل لنا ان الحوار الوطني سوف يكون حوارا
مفتوحا يشرك الجميع ولكن من الواضح الان
ان هذا الحوار سوف يكون ضيقا بين اشخاص
يتفقون بشكل اساسي في الاراء لا يمكننا ان
نرى حركه حقيقيه ونقاشا حقيقيا بشان
المستقبل اذا ما كنا نمنع الناس الذين
لديهم اراء سواء كانوا صحفيين كتاب اشخاص
في طيف السياسيه المصري اذا ما كانت
الحكومه تمنع هؤلاء من التعبير عن ارائهم
وبالتالي التاثير على المستوى الدولي سوف
يكون سيئا للغايه بالنسبه الى مصر وانا
ارى ان به الانباء اليوم تجسد ان التشدد
في القرارات في مواجهه الاراء المستقله لا
يزال قائما وطالما ان الحال هو ما هو عليه
في مصر هناك ثقه قليله جدا بالحكومه
المصريه وبان باستطاعتها ان تقوم بتغييرات
حقيقيه
والامين العام السابق للاتحاد الدولي
للصحفيين وحدثنا من لندن شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
خلفت الحرائق التي شهدتها الجزائر عشرات
القتلى والجرحى
واتلفت الاف الهكتارات من المساحات
الغابيه وقد اعلنت السلطات قرب انتهاء
عمليات الاخماد بشكل كلي تزامنا مع بدء
تحقيقات قضائيه حول ما اذا كانت هناك
دوافع اجراميه وراء اندلاع الحرائق كما
اعلنت السلطات عن بدء تعويض المتضررين
قتلى وجرحى وخسائر كبيره في الممتلكات
هذا هو المشهد في قريه ايت او صالح
بمرتفعات ولايه بجايه
بتحبينا حاجه برك عبد العزيز فقد سبعه من
افراد عائلته
هذه نقولها عند ربي
هذه نقدر نقولها عند ربي لا اله الا الله
محمد رسول الله خلفت الحرائق المتزامنه في
ظروف مناخيه صعبه عشرات القتلى والجرحى
وقد كافح رجال الاطفاء لساعات طويله
لاخماد السنه اللهب واجلاء المتضررين
وايوائهم في مناطق امنه
نصبنا اللجان على مستوى الولايه وعلى
مستوى الدوائر البلديات لاحصاء لاحصاء كل
احتياجات فيما يخص كل القرى على مستوى
الولايه ان شاء الله بينما هب الناس
للمساهمه مع رجال الحمايه المدنيه في
الاطفاء تساءل البعض عن تزامن هذه الحرائق
في عده مناطق من البلاد
النيابه العامه في الولايات المتضرره فتحت
تحقيقات جنائيه واعلنت قياده الدرك
الجزائري توقيف عده مشتبه فيهم وتقديمهم
للتحقيق بشبهه الضلوع في افتعال النيران
تكفف قرى الولايات التي حاصرتها الحرائق
حزنها في صمت فقد خلفت النيران الماسي
عشرات الوفيات والمصابين وخسائر في
الممتلكات وفيما اعلنت السلطات انها ستعوض
المتضررين فان الغطاء الغابي يتطلب وقتا
حتى يتجدد
الجزيره الجزائر
هذا وتعمل فرق الدفاع المدني وجهاز حراسه
الغابات والجيش التونسي على اخماد سلسله
حرائق اندلعت بعدد من الولايات وقال
الدفاع المدني في تونس ان فرقه سيطرت على
الحريق الاكبر في منطقه ملوله بمحافظه
جندوبه موضحا ان الجهود مستمره للسيطره
على حريقين اخرين مراسل الجزيره يرصد
جانبا من الحرائق 30 دلعت في منطقه ملوله
شمال غربيه تونس
نحن الان في قلب غابات منطقه ملوله
الجبليه بمدينه طبرقه بولايه جندوبه
الحدوديه مع الجزائر في هذه الغابات
اندلعها يوم امس حريق امتدا على مئات
الهكتارات اليوم جهاز الدفاع المدني يقول
انه سيطر بشكل شبه كامل على هذا الحريق
وبقيت بعض الجيوب التي تلاحظون هنا وهناك
والتي تجتد بين الحين والاخر بسبب اولا
ارتفاع مستوى الرياح وايضا درجات الحراره
المرتفعه في هذا الوقت من فصل الصيف بل
وحتى درجات الحراره القياسيه التي تسجلها
تونس والتي بلغت مستويات قياسيه او لم
تسجلها حتى تونس لمده او منذ عقود
في هذه المنطقه في منطقه ملوله يوم امس
هناك بعض المناطق السكنيه التي تم اجلاء
سكانها تم وضع الاولويه
لانقاذ المواطنين ومن ثم انقاذ ممتلكاتهم
وايضا العمل على اطفاء الحرائق سواء من
جهاز الدفاع المدني من جهاز
حراسه الغابات وايضا كان هناك تدخل من
الجيش الوطني لدعم مجهودات اطفاء الحرائق
ايضا ووفق سلطات الصحيه تقريبا اغلب
الاصابات كانت نتيجه الاختناق او الاغماء
وايضا بعض الحروق البسيطه ولكن تم تسجيل
وفاه لمواطن نتيجه الاختناق ولكن في منطقه
او في المدينه
بولايه باجه الان هناك ايضا نتيجه ارتفاع
درجات الحراره هناك سلسله حرائق في اكثر
من ولايه تونسيه سواء في ولايه باجه وفي
ولايه القيروان وفي ولايه سليان وفي ولايه
بنزرت وولايه
القصرين تم فتح بحث تحقيقي ولكن الاغلب
وفق عديد
الشهادات بان السبب الرئيسي يعود اولا
للارتفاع القياسي لدرجات الحراره وايضا
لهبوب رياح الرياح الحاره او ما يطلق
عليها برياح الشهيلي سيف الدين بوعلام
الجزيره من منطقه ملوله بمدينه طبرقه
بولايه جندوبه
اعتمدت الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
قرارا يستنكر اي اعمال ترتكب ضد الرموز
الدينيه والكتب المقدسه معتبره تلك
الاعمال انتهاكا بالقانون الدولي واخفقت
اسبانيا في تمرير تعديل على مشروع القرار
تقدمت به نيابه عن الاتحاد الاوروبي
يقترحوا حذف الاشاره الى انتهاك القانون
الدولي
وسبق للجمعيه العامه اعتماد القرار ذاته
في عامي 2019 و2021 في اطار تعزيز الحوار
والتسامح بين الاديان والثقافات ومكافحه
خطاب الكراهيه
وفي خبر اقتصادي يبدا بنكاء مصر والاهلي
المصريان طرح شهادات ادخاريه بالدولار
الامريكي بعائد سنوي يتراوح بين سبعه
وتسعه في المئه سنويا لتكون بذلك الاعلى
من نوعها من حيث العائد تاتي هذه الخطوه
وفقا لمحللين في اطار اجراءات مصريه
لتدبير الاحتياجات من النقد الاجنبي
وتشجيع الادخار بالدولار وتحويلات النقد
الاجنبيه من الخارج اضافه الى مواجهه
الفجوه بين سعر الصرف الرسمي وغير الرسمي
المعروف حاليا بالسوق السوداء وقال بنك
مصر في بيان انه طرح شهاده القمه
الدولانيه القيمه الدوليه ذات العائد
السنوي البالغ 9% للمصريين والاجانب على
ان تصرف مقدما لمده ثلاث سنوات بنسبه 27%
بالجنيه المصري
بينما قال البنك الاهلي المصري انه طرح
شهادتين بعائد مماثل مع اتاحه الفرصه
للاقتراض بضمانها بنسبه 50% من قيمتها
وذلك ب 10 ملايين جنيه كحد اقصى لاغراض
استثماريه
قبل الحصاد اجرينا مقابله مع وزير
الخارجيه البريطانيه جيمس
وسالته بدايه عن الهدف من الجوله التي
يقوم بها في الشرق الاوسط
علاقات قويه مع دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
وقطر وهي وجهه الاولى في هذه الجوله شريك
مهم للمملكه المتحده لدينا سرب قتاليه
مشترك والاول من نوعه في العالم ولدينا
تعاون دفاعي مشترك وناجح وبالتاكيد كنت
هنا خلال
الاستضافه الناجحه
لكاس العالم والذي اعتقد انها اظهرت قطر
على انها
مضيف فعال كانت كان كاس العالم ناجحا جدا
وانا هنا من اجل تعزيز هذه العلاقه
وقد قضيت وقتا قيما هنا مع اصدقائي في
الحكومه القطريه
حسنا اذا ما ذهبنا الى ما يحدث في اسرائيل
الانقسام الكبير الذي يحدث بالنسبه للحنيف
الاقوى وهو الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ترى بما فيهم رئيس بايدن انما يحدث يهدد
فكره وجود اسرائيل ما رايكم انتم
علاقات وثيقه وقويه مع اسرائيل وهذه
العلاقه القويه تعني بانها بامكاننا ان
نتحدث بشكل مباشر وصريح مع حكومه اسرائيل
بالتاكيد ما نشعر به ان التغييرات
الدستوريه يجب ان تحصل داخل البلد لكننا
نريد ان نضمن ان اسرائيل تحمي استقلاليه
النظام القضائي اعتقد ان هذا عنصر مهم
واسرائيل كانت تاريخيا تفخر بهذا الامر
نريد ان نضمن ان هنالك
دعم الواسع لهذه التغييرات بالتالي يجب ان
تتخذ الحكومه قرارات وخطوات لتوحيد الناس
بدلا من خلق الانشقاقات وبالتاكيد في اي
نظام اي مؤسسه نظام المؤسسات يجب ان يكون
هنالك ضوابط وتوازنات بالتالي هذه هي
الامور التي سنذكرها لمحاورينا في اسرائيل
مع دول العالم الاخرى في تمانيه لاسرائيل
النجاح
والرفاهيه وايضا نضمن ان نكون هنالك نظام
قضائي قوي ومستقل
تغول وسيطره اليمين المتطرف على الحكومه
وهو الذي لا يؤمن بحل الدولتين ويسعى الى
قظم المزيد من الاراضي الفلسطينيه الى اي
مدى يعيق جهود المجتمع الدولي بما فيها
انتم لاحلال السلام
المملكه المتحده كانت دائما قويا لحل
الدولتين وكان هذا سياسه طويله الامد تجاه
الاسرائيلينه والفلسطينيين في علاقه وسيظل
كذلك كنا دائما ندعم القرارات التي نعتقد
انها
تحقق امكانيه تحقيق فكره الدولتين وايضا
نتعامل بحذر مع اي شيء قد يقوض هذا الامر
ان ارى ان الكثير من الاسرائيلين غير
مرتاحين مع بعض القرارات التي تم اتخاذها
وهذا شيء يجب
ان تستمع اليه الحكومه الاسرائيليه لكن في
نهايه المطاف نريد ما هو الافضل للشعب
الاسرائيلي وللفلسطينيين ايضا وهذا هو
السلام والاستقرار وهذا سيظل الهدف
النهائي لسياسه الخارجيه للمملكه المتحده
في المنطقه
وما هي الجهود التي تبذلونها في بريطانيا
لحل الازمه في السودان وفي اليمن
الذي رايناه مؤخرا في السودان ومع تصاعد
العنف
والحاجه الى اجلاء الكثير من الاشخاص كان
مقلقا للغايه وقد عملنا
مع اصدقائنا
في الولايات المتحده
والدواء الذين لعبوا دورا فاعلا وايضا
حكومه المملكه العربيه السعوديه قد لعبت
دورا مهما بالاضافه الى مصر ودول اخرى في
المنطقه نستمر بالعمل بشكل مباشر عندما
نستطيع ذلك
مع الجنرالين في السودان وعملنا بشكل مقرب
مع اصدقائنا في المنطقه وقد قدمنا مساعدات
من اجل تخفيف المعاناه لكن في نهايه
المطاف فان قدرتنا على دعم الشعب السوداني
بشكل كبير اذا ما تم التوصل الى حل سلمي
بين جنرين بالتالي سنستمر بالضغط بشكل
ثنائي ومع اصدقائنا في المنطقه من اجل
تحقيق السلام في السودان
بالنسبه لليمن انا ارحب بالهدوء الذي
رايناه مؤخرا لكن بالتاكيد ليس لدينا
تسويه نهائية لذلك الوضع ان مسرور ان
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والجمهوريه اسلاميه الايرانيه قد تمكنت
امن عقد حواري يبدو وكانه قلل من بعض
العنف لكن في نهايه المطاف نريد ان نعمل
نحو تسويه نهائيه بالتالي يتمكن الشعب
اليمني ان يعيشوا في امان اكبر وان يحققوا
رفاهيه اكبر والمملكه المتحده ستستمر بلعب
دور فعال كما قمنا دائما ولسنوات عديده
في سؤال اخير وانتم تستضيفون قمه للذكاء
الاصطناعي هل تعتقد ان المخاوف من الذكاء
الاصطناعي مخاوف مبرره
الاصطناعي حاله كحال اي تطور تكنولوجي
لديه الفرصه في ان يقوم بتسريع الجوانب
الايجابيه والسلبيه في المجتمع ما تريد
المملكه المتحده ان تحققه وان تستخدم
قدرتها على
دعوه دول واشخاص من مختلف انحاء العالم من
اجل مناقشه كيف بامكاننا ان ننتهز هذه
فرصه فرصه الذكاء الاصطناعي لكننا قمنا
بوضع اطر عمل من اجل حمايه الجميع ليس فقط
المملكه المتحده لكن كل دول العالم من
التاثيرات السلبيه المحتمله لذكاء
الاصطناعي هذا هو الشيء الذي يجب ان نقوم
به على مستوى دولي بالتالي سنقوم بدعوه
عدد من الممثلين من ان دول من في انحاء
العالم من اجل ان نجري هذا النقاش ولهذا
انا تراست اول اجتماع
لمجلس الامن حول الذكاء الاصطناعي
ونحن نعرف ان هذا الامر سيكون عنصرا مهما
للمجتمعات الحديثه وايا كانت النتائج التي
سنواجهها علينا ان نتعاون مع بعضنا البعض
ومع اصدقائنا وشركائنا في العالم هذه هي
بدايه هذه الخطوات لكن المملكه المتحده
فخوره جدا بانها تلعب دورا قيادي في
التفكير في هذه التكنولوجيا المهمه وزير
الخارجيه البريطاني جيمس كليفري شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذا اللقاء
[موسيقى]
في فقره المتابعه نسلط الضوء على بدء
عمليه سحب حموله ناقله النفط صافر
المهجوره منذ سنوات قباله ميناء الحديده
اليمني الاستراتيجي في البحر الاحمر وهي
عمليه معقده تهدف الى تجنب كارثه بيئيه
وفق الامم المتحده من المتوقع ان يستغرق
نقل النفط اكثر من مليونين بل اكثر من
مليون برميل من خان مارب الخفيف ناقل ذلك
الى السفينه الجديده قد يستغرق ثلاثه
اسابيع ترسو صافر التي صنعت قبل 47 عاما
وتستخدم منصه تخزين عائمه منذ الثمانينات
على بعد نحو 50 كيلومترا من ميناء الحديده
الاستراتيجي الذي يعد بوابه رئيسيه لدخول
الشحنات غربيه اليمن
نظرا لموقع السفينه في البحر الاحمر اي
تسرب قد يكلف مليارات الدولارات يوميا اذ
سيتسبب باضطرابات في مسارات الشحن بين
مضيق باب المندب وقناه السويس في مارس
الماضي اشترت الامم المتحده السفينه
نوتيكا بهدف سحب الحموله ويتنازع طرفان
اليمني ملكيه النفط والسفينه التي سيتم
تغيير اسمها ليصبح اليمن يرى خبراء ان
نجاح العمليه ليس مؤكدا بسبب درجات
الحراره المرتفعه والانابيب القديمه
وغيرها من العوامل التي تشكل تهديدات
محتمله
سبق ان حذرت الامم المتحده في عده تقارير
من ان السفينه قنبله موقوته قد تنفجر في
اي لحظه وتسبب كارثه بيئيه كبيره على
اليمن ودول عديده اذ تحمل السفينه
المتداعيه سافر اربعه اضعاف كميه النفط
التي كانت على
احدث تسربها كارثه بيئيه عام
1989 قبله الاسكا بنيت عام
1976 في اليابان كناقله نفط ضخمه منذ عام
1988 استخدمت كفزان عائم ومرفا بتصدير
النفط اليمني قباله ساحل راس عيسى في
محافظه الحديده غربيه اليمن على البحر
الاحمر وتامل الامم المتحده ان تزيل
العمليه التي تبلغ تكلفتها 143 مليون
دولار مخاطر وقوع كارثه بيئيه قد تتسبب
باضرار بنحو 20 مليار دولار وحذرت من ان
اي تسرب للنفط يمكن ان يصل الى الساحل
الافريقي ممكن ان يلحق اضرارا بالثروه
السمكيه على مدى الاعوام الخمسه والعشرين
القادمه ويقضي على 200 الف وظيفه
تنضم الينا من بيروت غوى
النكت المديره التنفيذيه لمنظمه جرين بيس
في الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
السيده غوى ما احتماليه ان تنجح هذه
العمليه
مساء الخير
بدايه نحن كتير سعيد سعيدين ببدء العمليه
لانه عمليه نقل النفط هيدا الموضوع نحن
عملنا لاجله لسناء مواد طويله بالتعاون مع
الامم المتحده
ومنظمات محليه مثل الحلم الاخضر فنحن كتير
سعيدين ببدء العمليه وكلنا على امل انه
تنجح العمليه لانه
يعني فشل العمليه هو
كارثه بقيه وانسانيه نحن عم نجرب نتفاداها
لنا سنوات
فكلنا امل ونحن على سيئه انه الامم
المتحده والشركه
سميت اللي عم تقوم بعمليه الانقاذ هني
اخذوا كل الاحتياطات والاجراءات اللازمه
اللي تفادي اي كارثه ولكن مما لا شك فيه
هي عمليه معقده جدا
ولكن رغم تعقيداتها هي عمليه مهمه
ولا بديل عنها لتفادي لحضرتك سميته
القنبله الموقوته
يمكن ان يكون ولكن سماها الامير المتحده
ونريد يعني ان نسالكم ايضا لماذا هذه
التسميه ما الكارثه التي تجعل هذه الناقله
اكبر قنبله موقوته في العالم اليس هناك
يعني مبالغه في هذا التوصيف
لا للاسف هو ابدا ما في مبالغه ولهالسبب
كنا عم ندفع لنوصل لمرحله تفريغ
صافر مثل ما حضرتك ذكرت سافر في حال اي
تسرب نفطي حيكون اربع اضعاف تسرب
اللي حضرتك ذكرته
وليست محدوده الكارثه بالكارثه البيئيه
ولكن هي ممكن تكون اسوا كارثه انسانيه
واقتصاديه وبيئيه في البحر الاحمر نطاق
واسع ابعد من
اليمن فقط لانه اي تسرب نفطي بهذا الحجم
هو بدايه كارثه على منطقه معروفه بالتنوع
البيولوجي اللي فيها اللي هي البحر الاحمر
يقضي على الشعب المرجانيه مش بس
باليمن ولكن بكل الدول المجاوره لالها هو
ايضا
باثر على سبل عايش
اليمنيين اللي هن بيعتيشوا مثل ما حضرتك
بتعرف من صيد الاسماك
يفقدوا موارد رزق كمان حتتاثر محطات تحليه
المياه واكثر من عشره مليون شخص باليمن
والدول المجاوره حتفتقد لمياه الشرب نتيجه
هيك تسرب عدا عن التسرب النفض اللي ذكرناه
والاثر الاقتصادي
والبيئه اللي عليه والانساني واللي حيعطل
موانع الحديده واللي بتوصل عليها
المساعدات الانسانيه
في كان خوف من انفجار صراحه نتمنى بالفعل
ان تنجح هذه العمليه وكل التوفيق لمن يعمل
على ذلك وشكرا جزيلا لمشاركتك معنا من
بيروت غوى نكت المديره التنفيذيه لمنظمه
جرين بيس في الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
[موسيقى]
العنصريه في ملاعب كره القدم وارقام
قياسيه تقول منظمه
لدعم المساواه والاندماج في المجتمع انها
رصدت الابلاغ عن الف وسبعه حالات تمييز في
ملاعب كره القدم الانجليزيه خلال موسم
2022-2023 الكرويه يمثل ذلك زياده بنسبه
65% عن الموسم الكروي السابق اي الفين
2021-2022 وتشير المنظمه الى ان العنصريه
كانت حاضره في قرابه 50% من حالات التمييز
التي تشمل بطبيعه الحال ما يحدث في
الملاعب والاساءات على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي بخصوص منافسات كره القدم
اللافت ان المنظمه تشير الى زياده في
حالات التمييز المتعلقه بكراهيه الاسلام
المعروفه بالاسلام فوبيا بنحو ثلاثمائه في
المئه
والامل كل الامل ان تصبح ساحات كره القدم
وغيرها مكانا للتنوع والتسامح وليس العكس
ختام الحصاد لهذه الليله شكرا لكم